thank you to atlas vpn for sponsoring
this video
say it with me sunday monday tuesday
wednesday thursday friday and saturday
these days of the week shape the lives
of billions of people around the world
but why are there seven days in a week
in the first place
if you grew up in the western world you
probably have the idea that the week was
prescribed in the bible specifically in
the book of genesis where it states that
god made the earth in six days and
rested on the seventh day hence a seven
day week however this biblical story is
not where the week comes from instead
the story in genesis is describing and
giving a reason for a practice that
already existed
to find where the seven day week began
we have to go even further back to one
of the oldest civilizations in the world
back to babylon
[Music]
before we continue here's a quick word
from our sponsor and that sponsor is
atlas vpn we all like the internet right
with the internet we can learn new
things shop online and chat with friends
all over the world but the modern
internet isn't always safe and that's
where atlas vpn comes in atlas vpn
protects your internet travel which
means your data will be protected from
invasive tracking snooping and the
dangers of public wi-fi an atlas vpn
does even more than just protect your
data
using its data breach monitor it will
notify you when any personal information
has been compromised enjoy amazingly
fast speeds and protect an unlimited
number of devices
and it even helps you get the best deals
when shopping online but here's my
favorite part
so let's say like me you want to watch
top gear on netflix but you live in
america where top gear and many other
television shows and movies aren't
available well no problem just load up
atlas vpn scroll down pick the uk and
boom a whole new world of tv shows and
movies are available to you right now
atlas vpn is running a huge discount it
means you can get a three-year
subscription for just 199 a month with a
30-day money-back guarantee time is
running out so click the special link in
the description and get access to atlas
vpn's special deal with 82
off thank you again to atlas vpn for
sponsoring this video
before we check in with our babylonian
friends let's take a second to go over
some of the other methods of keeping
time
most other units of time are based on
astronomical phenomena a year is how
long the earth takes to orbit the sun a
month is how long the moon takes to
orbit the earth and a day is how long
the earth takes to spin once on its axis
however the weak has no such obvious
astronomical phenomena to tie it to
or does it
the first evidence of a seven day week
or at least some sort of important seven
day cycle is from ancient babylon in
2600 bc gudiya the priest king of lagash
built a seven-roomed tower in
celebration of a seven-day festival
the ancient babylonians recognized the
7th 14th 21st and 28th days of the month
as religiously significant
now we don't know exactly why the
babylonians chose seven days but there
are three theories that are pretty well
accepted among historians you see the
babylonians learning from their
forefathers the acadians were ardent
astronomers
even without any telescopes they mapped
the stars and followed the planets the
babylonians were the first to identify
many of the constellations that we know
today and these constellations are the
basis for the first theory explaining
the babylonians interest in the number
seven
you see in some of the most prominent
constellations like the big dipper which
the babylonians called the great wayne
or the pleiades which they simply called
the stars
among other constellations have seven
stars making them up
this was not lost on the babylonians who
seem to have taken this coincidence and
believed it showed a cosmological
importance to the number seven
while mapping the stars and
constellations the babylonians also
identified several other heavenly bodies
that didn't move like the rest of the
stars they called these bodies planets
and they're probably not the ones you're
thinking of at least not exactly
the babylonian astronomers labeled seven
planets
the moon the sun
mercury venus mars jupiter and saturn
keep in mind that this was thousands of
years ago and these ancient astronomers
didn't have the knowledge to understand
that not only are the sun and moon not
planets but also that the earth is a
planet
the fact that there were seven planets
further enforced the importance of the
number seven in babylonian culture there
is further evidence to support this
explanation for babylon's seven day week
based on the fact that they named the
days after the planets
the names of the planets were also the
names of some of their gods which was of
course a practice carried on to the
greco-roman world though we'll get to
that later the last theory explaining
the choice of a seven day week is the
fact that each phase of the moon happens
in roughly seven days
now in many ways this seems like the
most obvious explanation for the seven
day week but there's a problem to
consider the truth is it's actually not
that easy to figure out especially with
the methods the ancients employed how
long a lunar cycle actually is
and secondly
each phase of the moon isn't quite seven
days in some cases it can be eight days
to tell the truth all of these
explanations were probably responsible
in part for the adoption of the seven
day week by the babylonians it's
reasonable to assume that they observed
the constellations first then mapped the
phases of the moon and then discovered
the five planets and added them to a
list including the sun and moon which is
where the days get their names
but hold on that leads to another
question where did the names of the days
come from in english
well to answer that question we have to
look to rome the romans actually seemed
to have used an eight day week in their
earlier period and only adopted the
seven day week later making it official
during the rule of constantine
they adopted it as with so many things
from the greeks who in turn got it from
both the mesopotamians and the
israelites probably during alexander the
great's empire anyway the romans took
the seven day week and copied the greeks
and babylonians by naming the days after
their planets which were in turn named
for their gods
the romans spread their culture
including their weak all throughout
their empire
and even into the germanic tribes one of
which were the anglo-saxons who were the
first english speakers though their
language sounds very different from ours
used in a process scholars call
interpretatio germanica the germanic
people substituted some of their deities
for the roman deities
sunday and monday stayed the same so
diaz solis became sunindeg eventually
sunday
and diaz lunai became monandeg
eventually monday
the third day of the roman week was
named diaz martis named for mars the
roman god of war so the anglo-saxons
chose the one-handed god of combat tyr
so tiwa's dag meaning tears day
eventually evolved to tuesday
dies mercury was the next day named for
the messenger god mercury the
anglo-saxons somewhat strangely chose
vodin called odin by the norsemen the
all-father and king of the gods as their
replacement both deities have links to
magic and knowledge which is presumably
why they were seen as equivalent so the
day was called wundsdeg or woden's day
eventually turning to wednesday
dies yovis is next named for jupiter the
king of the olympians and god of the sky
the germanic equivalent was thunor or
thor in modern english thor the god of
thunder is perhaps the most famous of
the germanic gods thundra's dag was the
name given which evolved into thursday
the sixth day of the roman week was
called dias veneris named for venus the
roman goddess of beauty and love the
anglo-saxons chose frigg the wife of
odin and goddess of fertility and
motherhood as replacement
in some versions of germanic mythology
she is synonymous with the goddess
freyja who was the goddess of love and
beauty a bit more fitting as a
replacement for venus but in other
versions freya and frigg are two totally
separate goddesses the day was named
friggdag which is now friday
lastly we have saturday which unlike the
other days except arguably sunday and
monday was kept the same named for the
roman titan saturn the old god of
agriculture and father of the first
olympians
i hope you enjoyed learning about the
seven day week before you go i want to
again thank the sponsor of this video
atlas vpn follow the link in the
description below to protect your
internet privacy for just 199 a month
see you next time bye
[Music]